翻訳: Harumi Sukenaga
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさん こんにちは
私スタジオカタリストの松原と申します
今日は 皆さんに
「街づくりの触媒的手法」
「触媒的方法」という事について
お伝えしたいと思います
「触媒」って言葉を
みなさん聞いた事あると思います
小学校の化学の時間なんか
ちょっと思い出してください
二酸化マンガンと過酸化水素水
覚えておられます？
化学苦手やった？
あ それはよかった（笑）
過酸化水素水はその状態では
とても安定した物で変化しません
しかしここに触媒としての
二酸化マンガンを加えると
反応が起こって
水と酸素が生まれます
反応の主体は過酸化水素水で
二酸化マンガンは
変化反応前後で変化しません
この様な機能が「触媒」です
私はこの触媒という機能が
街づくりにおいても
重要だと考えて
そして 自分で独立して
事務所を起こす時に
その名前に
その意味を込めたかった
触媒を英語で訳すと「catalyst」
「カタリスト」です
で 私の事務所の名前は
「スタジオ カタリスト」です
それで 私がこの触媒的役割を
「街づくりの中で重要だ」
という風に考えたのは
あの20年前の
阪神淡路大震災の時でした
阪神淡路大震災の後
「街づくり」という言葉が
よく聞かれる様になったと
思います
今は幅広い意味になりましたが
この街づくりという言葉は
元々は公園を作ったり
あるいは道路を作ったり
住宅を開発したり
という様な どちらかと言うと
ハードを整備する様な
意味を持っていました
ところが 阪神淡路大震災以後は
色々とその活動の意味が
広がってきて
今では 地域に住む住民の皆さんが
自分達の力で自発的に活動して
そして自分の暮らす地域を
良くしていこうという
そういう活動を「街づくり」
という様になってきています
特にこの神戸市では
その住民主体の街作りを
支える制度や仕組みが
日本でも非常に早く
整えられてきた所です
1960年代70年代ぐらいから
そういう仕組みへの取り組みが
行われてきました
そうした 住民主体の街づくりを
支える仕組みがあった事が
20年前の阪神淡路大震災の後の
復興街づくりでも
大変効果的に
影響していった訳です
でも阪神淡路大震災の時は本当に
皆さん大変だったと思います
倒壊や火災で住宅がなくなり
多くの人が避難所や
仮設住宅での暮らしを
余儀なくされていました
その時の立場はそれぞれで
みなさんご苦労されています
でも一番最初には
行政と住民の立場の間で
非常に厳しい対立がありました
行政の立場からすると
限られた予算の中で
復興事業を早く進めて
「出来るだけ多くの人を元の姿や
元の暮らしに戻したい」
と思っておられる
そう言うやり方で一生懸命
速く進めようとしますが
住民の立場からすると
自分達の要望や考えを
何も聞いてくれないまま
受け止めてくれないまま
整備だけが 計画だけが進んでいく
そういう思いに
とらわれた方が多かった
実際に 震災の後は多くの市民が
市役所に駆けつけて文句を言う
というような
そういう厳しい対立がありました
その時にですね
こういう行政と市民が
それぞれ違う立場のなかで
復興を進めて行くなかで
あいだに立って
第三者的な役割を持って
この復興街づくりをスムーズに
進めていった役割の方がおられた
今現在60代から70代
ぐらいの方々で
「街づくりコンサルタント」と
いう呼ばれ方をしています
この皆さんは
分かりにくい行政の色んな事業を
分かりやすい言葉に翻訳して
住民さん 地域の方に説明をして
理解をしてもらって
その上で色んな様々な立場や
色んな意見を持った
住民の皆さん[の意見]を
丁寧に聞いて
そして概ね 皆が納得出来て
理解出来る提案としてまとめ
そのときにあった事業と整合性を
とりながら復興を進めていく
という役割を果たしました
対立して反応が起こって
いなかった状態に関わって
反応を起こして
復興街づくりを進めていく
私にはまさに触媒的な役割だ
という風に感じた訳です
その後
私はその頃 設計事務所の
下っ端にいた訳ですけれども
そういった先輩の仕事を
後ろで見させてもらいました
そして色々と
手伝わさせてもらいました
そして気づいた
その触媒的な役割を
その後の私の仕事の中でも
私なりに考えて
私のやり方を
探して行こうと思いました
その後の仕事では
山奥の小さな村や
老齢化の進んだ
オールドニュータウンや
あるいはこの六甲アイランドの
ようにまだ若いニュータウンや
場合によってはその地方の土地の
既成市街地の中心市街地とか
そういった色んな所に
関わらせて頂きました
その中で私が気づいたのは
こういう「触媒的役割」は
被災地だけの話ではなく
色んな人が暮らす地域
あらゆる所で必要ではないか
という事です
そしてこの触媒的な役割を
私なりにもう少し丁寧に言うと
相手の立場を尊重して
住民や地権者の方を尊重して
そしてその話をよく聞いて
そしてその人のやる気を促して
新しい関係性を生み出す
そしてその地域の方々
関わる方々が
自発的に自分の地域を
良くして行くようになる
それを促していくような役割
という事です
ではちょっとここで
私が関わった地域の事例を
ご紹介したいと思います
私は神戸市長田区の南の端
長田港のすぐ近くの駒ケ林
という所で
10年ぐらい 10年以上
街づくりを支援させて頂いてます
この駒ケ林をいう所は
2千年ぐらい前からの古い漁村で
大体 日本中の漁村はどこでも
狭い路地がいっぱいあります
しかもこの駒ケ林は戦争でも
阪神淡路大震災でも
被害は受けたんだけれども
火は出なかった
そういう事で古い建物が沢山
残っているわけです
道が狭く 古い建物が
沢山密集している
そういう所は災害があると
燃え広がり易くて
逃げにくい所です
神戸市内でも 最も
燃え広がり易くて逃げにくい
危険な地区だという風に
神戸市の中でも理解されています
そんな中でですね
私は例えば路地の整備だとか
路地のルールを決めるだとか
という様な事を進めてきました
仕事としてやって来ました
ただ ここの地域は 40年前の人口が
9千人あったのが
今は2700人ぐらいになっている
若い人がどんどんどんどん
外に出て行く
それに伴い 空き地や空き家も
増えている
言ってみれば 地方の
過疎村と同じ状態が
街中にあるのに生じている
という様な所です
こういう所の街を
持続可能な様にして
もっと活気を取り戻すには
なかなかハードな整備
だけでは上手く行かない
やはりそこに新しい人が関わって
その人が生み出す新しい社会関係
という変化が生まれなければ
なかなか本来的な意味での
街づくりにはなって行かない
その中で
最近街づくりに関わる
新しい変化が生まれています
その事例を少し
御紹介したいと思います
えっと これでいいかな？
この駒ケ林地区には
角野邸という建物があります
六甲アイランンドに美術館がある
小磯良平さんの
パトロンだった角野判次郎さん
というお金持ちが
私財を投じて作られた建物です
とっても良い建物なのですが
そして 地域の人も
「あそこはお金のかかった
良い建物やで！」というふうに
誇りにも思っておられる様な
建物なのですが
今相続人された方が
岡本の方に引っ越されて
20年ぐらい空き家になって
いました
なんとか地域の人が良い建物だと
思っているんだけれども
空き家の状態だった
今の所有者のお孫さんが
この建物を壊すか残すか
どうするかで
自治会長さんに
相談に行っていました
一方で 若手アーティストの
活動を支援する つまり
若手のアーティストが
自立するのを支援したり
社会への関係を上手く進められる
ような支援をしている
NPO法人の芸法さんっていう方が
おられました
この芸法さんは
若手アーティストの為の活動拠点
を地域に求めておられました
私はその両者を
知っておりましたので
これが街づくりに対して
上手く働かないかなという事で
私の役割がどんなんだろうか
という風に考えて
色々活動をしました
そしてその結果は
詳細はちょっと省きますけれど
最終的にこの建物が
それまで15〜20年
空屋だった建物が
若い人達のアートの
活動拠点になったわけです
地域の自治会長さんなども
自分の絵を並べたりと
地域に受け入れられる形での
若手の人達の
アートの拠点になった
そしてこの拠点が出来ると同時に
それまで駒ケ林とは縁が無かった
色んな分野の若い方が
この拠点の中に
訪ねて来る様になりました
こういう交流会を
用意されている中で
エコール神戸さんという若い方と
私達知り合いました
このエコール神戸さん
面白い活動をされています
軽度の知的障害の若い方々
高校卒業された方々に
学びの場がないという事で
学園をおこしました
そういう方々に教育の場を作って
運営している所です
そのエコール神戸さんは
その学生さん達が汚して
自分たちで表現できるような
アトリエが必要だと思うが
そういう場所がない
という風におっしゃってました
ところが一方
その駒ケ林の中では
元々住んでいたけれども
外に引っ越して
相続を受けた空き地や
空き家の処分に
困っているという方々が
神戸市に相談に来られた
両者の立場を知っていた私は
どういう役割をしたらいいかな
という事で 後で少し説明しますが
間を繋ぐ役割をして
そしてこの後ろに見えてる建物が
この関係する皆さんによって
改修された
そして この様に
軽度の知的障害者の方々の
アトリエに変わっていきました
さらにもうひとつ
この地域の自治会が元々
事務所として持っていた場所が
阪神淡路代大震災で建物が潰れて
空き地になっていた所があった
こういう空き地は
雑草が生えて虫が湧いて
非常に近隣に影響を与える
ここにも何か出来ないか?
今度は神戸市さんが
「まちなか防災空地」という形で
ここを防災拠点にする
それに対してなら
整備のお金を出してもいいよ
という様な仕組みがあった
そこを繋ぐ事によって
ここも新しく
生まれ変わったわけですが
この様に 日々は地域の方々の
日常的な憩いの場
そして災害の時は防災拠点となる
形に変化していったわけです
この場所では
いままで関わってこられた
芸法さん エコール神戸さん
そして地域のみなさんが
それぞれみんな
最後の仕上げを一緒に活動して
実現したということです
ここで私がしてきた役割は
例えばアーティストを支援する
活動ではありません
軽度の知的障害の方を支援する
活動でもありません
空き地を整備をして
綺麗にするのに
お金を出している
訳でもありません
私の役割は
それぞれ思いを持った方々の
話を丁寧に聞いて
そしてそれを尊重した上で
新しい関係性を作り
そしてその立場の皆様それぞれが
自発的に自分達の活動を行う事で
地域を良くして行く
その様な間の繋ぎ方を
私は役割としてした訳です
私がしてきたのは
この様に建築と都市計画の
分野の中でやってまいりました
ところが
この様な活動をして行く
中で 私が気が付いたのは
こうした触媒的な役割というものは
ひょっとしたら建築や都市計画の
分野だけに限らないんじゃないか
という事です
つまり 自分自身が
よくなるのではなくて
自分自身が関わる事によって
その関わる人や組織
そういった物が
自発的に良くなっていく
その様な関わり方が
あるのではないか
それは色んな分野で通用する
のではないかという事です
自分が成長して
自分がリーダーとなって
社会をひっぱって
社会を良くしてゆく
その様なあり方は 決して
否定される物ではなく
おそらく 望ましい姿の
１つだと思います
でもですね
そういう姿ばかりでは無いだろう
自分が関わる事によって
その関わった相手 他者や組織
といったものが
自発的に良くなって変わっていく
その様な関わり方
それはこれから色んな分野で
重要になっていくのではないか
特に これからの社会では
多くの人はフラットな関係の中で
それを構成して行きます
そういうフラットの関係の中では
互いを尊重して
お互いの意見をよく聞いて
そしてお互いに良くなっていく
それを促す様な役割
これが重要になってくるのでは
ないかと思います
皆さんが所属 活躍されている
例えば 大学のサークルや 研究室や
あるいは 会社の中の
担当チームなど
そういった所での働きを
イメージしていただければ
分かり易いかもしれません
さて 私はこの様な形で
触媒的な役割というものを
上手く進めてゆくように
今まで考えてきた訳ですが
最後に こういう中で
役割を果たして行く中で
一番大切にしている事を
皆さんにお伝えしたいと思います
それは よい変化の可能性や兆し
これに気付く あるいは見いだして
その実現を図る 促す
その為の努力をするという事です
相手の立場を尊重して
そしてその話を丁寧に聞くならば
そしてまた関係性に
注意を払うならば
自分が考える良い変化の可能性
あるいは兆し
これが見つかるんじゃないか
と思います
そしてその実現を促す様に
努力をするという事が
大切なんじゃないかという風に
思っている所です
今日ご参加して頂いている
皆さんは
色んな分野から来て頂いている
という風にお伺いしております
皆さんが
それぞれの分野の中で
それぞれの活動をする時
あ ちょっと触媒的
自分じゃない 自分の周囲の人が
ちょっとよくなってくれる
自発的に良くなっていっている
そういう物に自分は何か
出来るんじゃないか?
少し頭の中に置いて頂けると
私は大変嬉しいです
今日は皆さん 私の話を聞いて
頂いてありがとうございました
（拍手）